next is mechanical at 34 percent
followed by civil at 27 this is the
employability scenario so does india
need
so many non-cs non-iit engineers the
demand and supply uh must be balanced
you have to declutter the curriculum so
we have we have done we have shown our
leadership in software services i.t
services
but time to move on into hardware as
well my message is whatever you're doing
do the best
as you probably know we have a number of
surveys and education reports coming out
every year
we have uh the all india survey of
higher education so the latest report
came out i think in
june or july 2021 and it tells us about
the numbers from 2019 20 academy here so
let me just pull out the numbers for you
here
so
uh this gives us the picture of
enrollment at the undergraduate level
we have the picture across all domains
starting from arts to science commerce
but we are going to focus only on
engineering and technology
so
computer engineering and they make it a
distinct domain from i.t and computer
science so computer engineering
as per the report of 2021
we had a total
in the entire country so this is taking
into account all the different
institutions iit's every uh from tier
one to tier three tier four whatever
tier you want to take everyone included
935
thousand students
okay so more than nine lakh students
this is just computer engineering and
then
if we also include
uh i.t and computer science
it's an additional
seven lakh sixty seven thousand students
so in total we have almost seven
one point seven million students
one point seven million students in
computer engineering i t and computer
science
and then we have guess what mechanical
engineering
that's the second in number
the total number of students is
6 lakh 84 926
okay so this is almost seven lakh
students uh and then we have electronics
engineering civil engineering and and
many others okay
so
the the number here is that we have
almost seven lakh students just this is
just at the undergraduate level so if
you if you talk about the employer
employee dynamic this is on the supply
side of the thing
uh you also have something called the
india higher education report 2020 and
they quote something uh
called a report on the on the
engineering employability from
something called aspiring minds 2019
where they say that
as
high as 80 percent of the students are
unemployable
just imagine
so this is their data eighty percent of
the students are unemployable whether
they get employed or not that's a
different story altogether this is the
picture as far as their potential goes
so this is one report and you know i
mean you can have different criteria and
you can end up with different kinds of
numbers so uh just for comparison we
have another report so this is from a
firm called vbox
and they had as their academic partner
aicte all in your council of technical
education
uh and they conducted a post pandemic
survey
and they also conducted their own um
taylormade for their own purposes uh
some kind of an employability study uh
they had a test for more than 65 000
students indian students
and they found out overall
that these are the numbers
for the employment
for i.t
uh students
the employability stands at 48
so mind you that this 48 percent is
calculated based on
uh a pass mark of 60 percent in their
own test so if the student scored 60 or
higher they are considered employable so
students from iit they got 48 percent
and this is the highest across all
domains
the highest overall is for engineering
domains but within this more granulated
picture is 48 percent
electrical engineering is 47 percent
electronics and communication is 40
percent
computer science
comes next at 38
next is mechanical at 34 followed by
civil at 27 percent this is the
employability scenario
now if we if we if we look at it a
little bit into more detail
uh they do take into account when they
are talking about employability certain
things which are of immediate necessity
in the post-pandemic era
so this is not to say that this is the
condition that is always going to be and
we also know that statistics can lie so
we have to take this with a grain of
salt there's a lot of nuance going on
but the overall picture
is
uh
on the grim side
i we all have to agree to this
so the question it boils down and this
is probably the most striking
part of the whole discussion today and
i'm sure i'm going to offend many people
when i ask this question does india need
okay so does india need
so many non-cs non-it engineers
given these numbers
okay i know there is no clear cut answer
for this but perhaps if you can have
some discussion on this
there's no resolution to this i know
there's no immediate resolution of this
but does india need so many non-cs
non-iit engineers especially if we talk
about the kind of engineers uh that are
being trained quote unquote trained in
uh
in colleges which are uh for lack of a
better word whose only purpose is profit
making so this is something to to think
and worry about
no jivana as you said i mean this is a
very
this is a very deep question and all of
us need to introspect on this one
the demand and supply uh must be
balanced
okay and
if we are training engineers in a
certain domain and we don't have
one one ways we don't have enough
enough jobs to employ them that is one
side of the problem
but the other problem that comes out of
the statistics is
even though we are giving them the
degrees
we are probably not
at least as per the
you know standards set by this agency
these most of this
more than seven more than what sixty
percent of these
graduates are not meeting those minimum
expected standards
um based on which they can be called
employable
so that's a very worrisome
picture as you as you have rightly
pointed out and we cannot sit back and
you know just just have discussions on
those it's time to act
and this is where i think that now what
is employable i i didn't touch about uh
i don't know what are the metrics that
were used over there what were the
things but if you ask me from if i have
to
hire someone what is it that i have to i
will be looking in that candidate during
the interview
one is of course the technical knowledge
depth is important and probably that's
why the standard of
technical education that is imparted
needs to be checked and there has to be
some monitoring of that definitely
okay
now other than that
it is however also important given that
today we are in an extremely
multi engineering i'm talking about it's
it's an extremely multi-disciplinary
domain
okay today in today's world
and if you sometimes we may even
sit back and think that whether
this classical
compartmentalizations of mechanical
electrical electronics chemical
are relevant today
okay
because
when you go to the industry
it is uh you are a gas turbine engineer
maybe
okay
or or a semiconductor engineer
so what that means is you need to have
knowledge in several fields you may have
in-depth knowledge in one
but you should acquire some knowledge in
adjacent fields as well
and you know the word technology is t
right so t there is a one stem so that
is your that is the depth
and then you have two wings which is the
bread
okay you need to have both
okay so therefore in
today's world i'm talking only about the
technical side right now
uh but the students also while studying
and even the educational institutes
should set up options like microsoft
specializations which you know as iits
are doing
i may be
i i have a b-tech in mechanical
engineering major this concept of major
and minor has been there in the west
especially in the us for many many years
okay is a major in mechanical
engineering minor in music
right so here also micro specialists
even if it's in technical areas
these people inherently are good in
mathematics
so therefore a person can be
a major in mechanical engineering or
chemical engineering
and has a micro specialization in
analytics in data analytics
so that will
and today machine learning ai which is
which are the hot areas today
so people also even the students also
have to be nimble
and pick up these skill sets
during especially during the formative
years when you know the ability to pick
up and comprehend new things is much
more than
then maybe at somebody at my age today
so people should make fully fully
utilization of that
and the educational institute should
also
have options
for students to enroll in such
and to pick up these adjacent skills
which is going to make them
you know more employable
this is i i believe this is important
and something that
all of us need to think about that also
means that we have to declutter which i
think something you were talking about
before you have to declutter the
curriculum we cannot bottle up the
student from 8 am to 5 pm every day in
classroom lecture after lecture after
lecture
and then expect him
i think then and now coming back to your
other point whether it's
non-cs
yeah that's an unfortunate part we
probably at this point where we are
today in our country
uh we probably don't have
so many core jobs in
in every core industry probably much and
and especially compared to i.t
um mechanical engineering won't have
that many jobs so therefore
how do we do this i am very hopeful that
now at least people are talking about
uh you know focusing on manufacturing
and making actual products in india it's
not going to happen overnight but at
least the talk is there
in my own field i know people are
talking about semiconductor
manufacturing
so we have we have done we have shown
our leadership in software services i.t
services but time to move on into
hardware as well so once that happens i
believe a lot of new jobs
will be created i am hopeful
that lot of new jobs will be created in
the more traditional
fields of what we call the physical
science based engineering
so that is our hope but that hope i
think in if everything goes well if
everything goes well even that hope uh
in order to get implemented uh it won't
be before let's say five ten years even
optimistically speaking right so uh in
this scenario it's very hard to
prescribe a solution to students who may
be in their second year or third year
right now
uh maybe in these tier three colleges uh
something like that they are already
maybe in uh they have already taken
mechanical engineering they have already
taken civil engineering and they are at
this at this very dangerous sort of
crossroads so what we are discussing
here
it may be
i mean seem rather depressing and grim
to them so
could we perhaps
i mean give as a prescription to them
what you have earlier mentioned a number
of times to
ah to start this attitude of nimbleness
this this flexibility and without
getting hung up that i have to do only
and only
work on turbo machinery because i like
studying it very much rather being
flexible enough that okay the market
demands me to do this
i have a family to take care of my
family didn't
i mean send me to to engineer to an
engineering institute to become
intellectual rather to rather to support
those families so uh
well that is true as a bit of a
sacrifice be flexible enough to maybe
learn what the
market wants you to learn and get a job
and then maybe try to orient you once
you once you get into the industry like
the overall industry maybe try to tune
your efforts in directions which where
where your
your programming skills with your ai
machine learning and all the buzzword
skills can be applied to domains which
have to do with your core interests
and yeah i think picking up these skills
that are relevant in today's world is
very important okay and let me tell you
it's not like something i don't like or
like
if you if you do something sincerely
you will start liking them yeah it's a
bad like marriage don't you think
you often fall into you you don't have
to always fall in love and get married
you can always get married and fall in
love also that has worked for
foreign generations
thermal and fluids
i did survive at intel for many years
now
of course mechanical engineering and
thermal management
remained my core work
but it was important
to also learn
about the other domains as well
learn it to an extent where i can
participate in a meaningful conversation
with people working in those domains i
don't have to be an expert
but can i give my inputs
okay that can i give some useful and
valuable inputs so that is what we have
to pick up and learn okay and what is it
that i mean nobody what is it that
putting this label that i'm a mechanical
engineer four years back i was not i was
just a class 12 pass out right okay so
four years later i can be something else
my message is whatever you're doing do
the best okay because when i look at
when i look at a resume or a cv
to be honest i mean grades only give us
one part of the story your cgpa or your
percentage marks
you know it is not always a true
reflection of the caliber of the of the
candidate
but you know what it tells me it tells
me that this person was sincere
okay he had the decision yeah he was
studying he was sincere he valued the
education and he did well
okay so therefore if he comes to my
company i will give him a job which may
be completely unrelated
but he or she will do that sincerely
with proper guidance
and give me the output that i want i
think you have touched upon a very very
important point here so a high cgpa or a
respectable cgpa it doesn't necessarily
indicate technical expertise because i
mean in the semester system it's very
difficult for you to really master any
subject
but then what it does really indicate is
that
you had the discipline to to do what you
were asked to do
yeah
absolutely and it it does matter please
let me tell you okay maybe there are
many students you may have
sometimes you know you may have heard
some stories from your seniors no no
work on this
develop your leadership skills but i
these are important as i come always say
i've consistently been saying but not at
the expense of your academics yeah
go to class understand what is being
taught we don't have engineering is not
rocket science if you understand what is
taught in class you will do well if you
comprehend internalize it you will do
well it's very difficult to fail in
engineering
okay if you if you're not doing well it
means you did not study okay so please
do that because otherwise what happens
is if i see somebody with a low score i
would say
he can find him he must be he may be
good he may be bright etc
but maybe he was not motivated so what
is the guarantee that if i hire him he
will he will deliver i know he has a
capability but
i i will have question mark on the
sincerity and disagree i may be wrong i
i it is it is possible that there is
some spark which was ready to be ignited
and maybe if i hire him or her i may be
able to do that
that's that's also fine but i have to
see that spark in this series somewhere
right okay so
it's important it's very important that
you be sincere about whatever branch you
are studying in
and and then even in life also whatever
you do just give your best in that